l tutti ragazzi pervenuti a questo video
sono bravi se vengo ho deciso di
documentare questa settimana incredibile
di fare una raccolta e di buttarci
dentro pezzi a caso di cosa è successo
che odore strano
o scoraggiato
non dovendo ragazzi non è tanto il
camion dei pompieri il problema ma che
sui cartelloni di milano in alto c'è la
schermata di windows che bello
ripristino avvio windows non riuscito è
bellissimo so che è successo
no si è spento ma che c'hai riavvio
aspetta che pubblicità windows gratis si
spegne e bellissima ecco cos'è
ripristino all'avvio c'è qualcuno tipo
in mansarda che sta facendo noi li
chiedono 9 gli penso sia importante la
sola mila only milano poi ragazzi gente
al parco o mi butto in mezzo
così vi faccio riconoscere a caso
ciao ha funzionato regalo fai da te in
casa mia c'è l'antincendio no però se
tutto quanto si bagna sono cazzi tua chi
ha queste faccende misto che bello ma mi
fai schifo fai schifo giù alle richiesta
di non fare bordello a casa mia mi trovo
tutto il caffè qui sotto è stato lui è
stato lui lo riconoscete in faccia bene
le botte pesanti ma dai ragazzi questo è
nicolas che sta provando ad accendere il
forno mettere la giusta non allora scott
ad insegna europa vj alle prese con il
cuore che con il cuoco con dati che non
funziona non c'è niente ma non ci sono i
tassi sembra il launch pad
ma cos'è casse clicca o la redige
chiedo solo un ora ci sono tre tasti
quindi questi tre nomi non schiacciare
non è che quante persone ci vogliono per
spegnere un forno non è possibile ma al
centro e cimici il sale grosso e sa
limited edition di assassin's creed ma
ci sono i fornelli e il sale grosso
lo abbiamo fatto dio mio al 14 ore e
mezzo permette sta merda di piano
cottura pedali cristoforo caffè
colombiano si sta bene
non lo so che schifo dai
l'altra volta
dove andate voi 57 rabbia dare la vita
per sei veramente in scena oddio ma che
cazzo fai veramente ha fatto questa cosa
perché guarda i nemici ma no che vi sta
guardando ma cosa cazzo fa un deficiente
non deficit niente ragazza
io allora confermare un cellulare anno
in teoria dato la firma
tieni al tuo cellulare cofirmato bene
basta maschi mamma sono pronto per
andare a scuola
ce la facciamo noi mica scapito di chi
guarda alla sedia 6 spider merda adesso
ora c'è il bambino lynch ha il mio
stesso identico giubbotto uguale uguale
lo stesso
lo so
può fare il bambino 1 quale bambino io
siete facciamo fatto
i bambini
sto cercando jacopo che non è lei si
cercano di a capo dei punt hellas mi
deve venire a prendere con una clio
mi ha detto che vicino a un bar però i
non ho idea di come sia fatta una clio e
né tantomeno come sia dato un bar non so
come è fatta una cazzo di clio
cos'è una clio cos'è cliomakeup porca
eva non è la macchina io di macchine mi
intendo quanto si intende mia madre di
facebook con una tristezza incredibile
ha fatto ragazze gli anni 6 anni per
trovarci mica incredibile amici sotto
sequestro nella soluzione delle se in
realtà non stiamo andando a registrare
nulla mi sequestri e boe che rischiavamo
in un garage è giusto così bello e tu no
delle proprie dario siamo in punto è che
non esiste non è in italia si chiama e
una nuova regione nel nostro paese chat
che bello ha preso il tronco adesso va
craftare la casa in macchina ed entriamo
finalmente compriamo sul suo canale
cazzi incredibile veramente ti volevo
dire ciao mamma sono stufa vgt vinci
nalmente dopo negli ai crediti proprio
il traguardo della vita che voi ci
crediate o no reagan non è finto questo
posto esiste esiste enorme c'è
praticamente un posto gigantesco e ci
sono tutti gli stand dei dei giocattoli
poi c'è odio ditemi che non posso fatto
almeno di questi
c'è la l'insalata offerta gentilmente da
giochi preziosi
l'insalata preziosa forchetta preziosa
cellulare prezioso google arcuti altri
del calendario sexy pamela david j
che bella nove ragazzi
altro che poster segue wow è roba
bellissima questa copertina il volare
leo leo le ho toccate